Donald Trump's lawyers are now turning
on each other it is getting very ugly
and predictably so law and crime has a
very good piece Trump's lawyers turning
against each other
legal experts react to the report that
Christina Bob said she was told to sign
the alleged false statement about
Mar-A-Lago documents this is really
interesting what's going on I mean of
course it's it's a train wreck it's a
car crash in every way but it's also
interesting legal Twitter was a buzz
over reports that one of former
president Trump's attorneys recently
spoke with Federal prosecutors about
various details regarding allegedly
classified documents discovered at
Mar-A-Lago according to NBC News uh
citing three sources familiar with the
matter attorney Christina Bob a one-time
talking head on one America news named
two other Trump attorneys involved with
the case during a recent talk with the
U.S department of justice as long crime
previously reported
Bob signed a letter in June of this year
um
saying that Trump had returned all
documents subject to a May grand jury
subpoena we know that wasn't true that
letter claimed Trump no longer had any
documents identified as classified at
his Florida State the statement Bob
signed however was allegedly authored by
Trump attorney Evan Corcoran according
to the New York Times the report is that
she now is saying I was told to sign it
I didn't believe that it was true I'm
another one of these victims here and
very very quickly it is not only
Trump attorneys getting attorneys but it
is Trump attorneys pointing the finger
at other attorneys now there's a
legitimate legal question how solid is
your defense if you say I knew it was
false but they told me to sign it
different legal opinions have come down
on this some say uh this is actually not
a crime that Christina Bob committed I'm
relaying what someone else told me as
long as she is telling the truth about
that and there is an evidence that this
was her idea her thought to sign and put
together this document that someone told
her to it to do it
you can make the case that she is not
committed any crime that's one legal
opinion the other legal opinion is she
is confessing that she knew that what
she was being told is false you know it
there's this legal idea of
um uh the lawyers are following what
their clients tell them they believe and
it is not really up to the lawyer to
determine whether they are being told
something that's true or false but if
she is admitting she knew that it was
false and still signed off on it I've
also read legal opinions that say no she
could also be in legal Jeopardy what we
know is Christina Bob was hired by Trump
for her ability to be a talking head on
television and that is often how Donald
Trump hires his lawyers we will have to
see where this all falls but it is an
extremely uh risky from a career
standpoint decision to agree to be
Donald Trump's attorney so Trump's
attorney is now pointing fingers at each
other and I predict in the next month
it's going to get very very interesting
where this Falls let me know what you
expect find me on Twitter at dpacman and
we will be back right after this